Speaker 1: All right, let's get into this
week's mailbag. You can email info at David
Pakman dot com to participate. Please don't abuse
that email address. We'll just block it. We have
many people whose emails are filtered directly
into the trash because they email us too much or
into a folder we keep in case law enforcement ever
asks for emails from people. Yeah, it does happen.
It does happen. Maybe stories to tell someday
about that? No. But in all seriousness, don't
abuse it, OK? Info at David Pakman dot com. Let's
jump right into our first email first. The email
is from Alexander, who says, I'll just get to the
point. You were a loser and always will be lost in
space. Sleepy Joe Biden and his administration
opened the eyes of so many that voted for him
by all of his screw ups since taking office,
and now realize what a stupid mistake it was
to have believed the lies of his campaign
message. 2024 is just around the corner,
and once again, America will be great again.
Under the leadership of President Donald Trump,
I disagree with the characterization of what
Trump's leadership would be, but I don't for a
second take issue with the very real possibility
that Donald Trump will be president again.
This country is dumb enough to do it again. They
were dumb enough to do it once when it was obvious
it would be a disaster. And it was, and they are
clearly eager to do it again. So it's going to
come down as it often does to turnout. There will
be, no matter what Trump does between now and 2024
other than maybe die, and even then they might
still put him on the ballot and vote for him,
no matter what Trump does between now and 2024.
There will be tens of millions of people, just
like the guy who emailed me, who will gleefully
vote for another four years of that insanity,
so we need to be prepared. I disagree. It'll
be great. But the emailer is absolutely right.
You very well could see Trump again in 2024, and
that's a very scary, scary thing. Here's another
very aggressive message. It's I'm going
to read it as written OK. And yeah,
well, well, gay Jews, boy. Ever thought that the
man you hate so much as the peacemaker in the
Middle East? Yea, Trump. No, you are so full of
hate and beside that so stupid not to see what his
what this dementia Joe Biden is doing to the USA.
Never a single word from you about the laptop full
of sex with underage girls. The money scam for the
big man from the Ukraine flying the Air Force One,
the can the private deal made. The Biden family is
the most big crime family ever in the White House.
Then he cannot speak one good word after the
other one great disaster. So tell me, boy,
how on earth can you not speak? Sorry. How
on earth can you put up with this and saying
nothing about it? Just get the news from more
good Democrats friends. That wall mark closed 22
stores in the left wing California. Why?
Because people can riot and lauding the stores
and would not get arrested. Yes, under Biden,
this will harm the whole USA. But you keep silent
about this. Gas prices up. Food $2 down.
Yes, gay boy, that's where you voted for.
But because you can know better will
not talk about this, but hang out with
the Trump old story. Happy day boy. All the
best. We know you need it, Fritz the with.
Yeah. Next, email, OK. Austin wrote to me
about Republican hypocrisy on co-morbidities.
David, I saw your recent segment on
Tucker reporting on Colin Powell's death.
I found it very interesting that for the duration
of the pandemic, Republicans were constantly
talking about how COVID deaths are overstated
and many people are dying from other causes.
For some reason, that all seemed to go
right out the window when Colin Powell died.
Now it's certainly a COVID death, implying Powell
wasn't already immune immunocompromised and had
apparently nothing to do with the other ailments
he was suffering from. Of course, as you stated,
this just has everything to do with undermining
the vaccine. Yeah, it is funny where before any
time anybody died of COVID, supposedly it
was like, No, no, no, no, no. They didn't
really die of COVID. They were killed by
doctors at hospitals. We covered that one.
They died from a car accident, but then they were
just tested for COVID. And because they had it,
it counts as a COVID death. They were marked as a
COVID death to the hospital could make more money,
et cetera. Now Colin Powell dies of Coke. Oh,
look at that. It's absolutely covered. Yeah,
the skepticism. Again, this is because none
of these are their values or their actual
underlying beliefs. It's just what can we say
today to make the point we're already determined
to make. That's that's quite simply what it is,
and it's a very good point. Nobody's saying,
Hey, you know what we've been saying for a year
and a half when someone supposedly dies of COVID?
We should be skeptical with Colin Powell. Nobody's
skeptical now. Yup. He died of COVID. No question
whatsoever. Biden's Christmas, Paul wrote to
me, saying, David, sir, does it not seem odd
that the people most worried that Christmas will
be ruined by supply chain issues are essentially
admitting not only that Christmas is not
primarily a celebration of the birth of Christ,
but that it is also a custom built
upon the giving of Chinese made goods.
I am not religious, but what happened
to Christ is the reason for the season.
What happened to buy American right wing
audiences can be convinced of the exact
opposite of what they espouse. Very bizarre stuff.
Yeah, Paul, this is sort of like another example.
Of you've got their stated principles. And then
you've got their actions when the principles no
longer correspond with the point they want
to make. There's an attack on Christianity
and it's all about Jesus and religiosity. And we
should buy American because we're Republicans. Oh,
we're having problems with Chinese supply chains.
That's going to ruin Christmas. No mention of
Jesus. No mention of buy-American. Just it's Joe
Biden's fault that we're not going to be able to
get our Chinese toys. Same analysis as before. You
know, none of the I don't know that they believe
any of the things they say. They'll use them to
make political points. If it's so convenient,
and that's about as far as it goes. Really good
message about the Dennis Prager thing. We talked
last week about how Dennis Prager tested positive
for COVID, and he's taking five medications, and
he said he wanted to test positive for it. Joe,
from Virginia, wrote in and said, Hey David,
do people like Dennis Prager not see the irony in
wanting to catch COVID in order to develop natural
immunity? They want to catch the virus in order to
develop antibodies so that they're less likely to
catch it again in the future. It makes no sense.
Why not just never catch it in the first place?
It's like if I told you I could hit you with a car
today and in exchange your chance of being hit by
a car in the future will be reduced. Reasonable
people would decline being hit with the car at
all. Getting vaccinated in this scenario, preggers
logic, if it can even be called logic, makes it
seem like he'd take on the car. Yeah, this is
something we've been talking about for a while.
We want to get COVID, get everybody sick,
so that then you're protected in the future.
Right. But millions of people would die with
the herd immunity approach. Why not just avoid
catching it if only there was something that could
reduce our chance of catching it? And of course,
that's something is the vaccine that they just
make no sense. There was a time, and maybe it
to some degree still applies, although I don't
know enough about it before there was any, any,
you know, chicken pox vaccine. There would be the
idea of you get your kids together so that they
pass chicken pox and you get get it out of the
way. Because getting chicken pox as an adolescent
or an adult or shingles, it can
be really, really, really bad.
So that's something that used to go on, like
when my parents were kids, even when I was a kid.
It was already not being done that I'm aware of.
But what Dennis Prager is saying, it's like I
want to get the virus to have a lower chance of
getting it in the future. Well, why not just get
the vaccine and reduce your chance of getting it
at all and try to avoid it? It seems more logical.
By the way, particularly when remember Vincent
Racaniello, one of the top virologists in the U.S.
from Columbia University? We interviewed him and
he said it would be expected. Generally speaking,
the trajectory over time would be that the
the coronavirus, the COVID 19 SARS-CoV-2
gets less serious over time. So there's really
not an advantage to getting it now. A very,
very strange stuff. But you know, none
of what they're doing makes sense.
Riley wrote to me about a teacher wearing a star
of David in protest of the vaccine, saying, Hey,
David, I thought this might catch your interest.
A Brenda's middle school teacher in Red Bluff,
California, posted this video comparing the
Holocaust to the vaccine mandate just to add
to the cringe. She cut out a star of David and
asks followers to pin them on their shirts as
part of a protest. She took down the original post
due to the outrage and reposted the same message,
this time with a blue star. Yeah, I saw
the original video with the yellow star,
and then I saw a subsequent video where the same
teacher then did a video with a blue star because
apparently the yellow star. A lot of people
said you're trivializing the Holocaust again,
like so many of these anti-vaxxers have done.
In fact, last week I told you about a report
that looked at COVID conspiracies, pushing
people either overtly or sort of in a more
below the radar way towards anti-Semitism.
Trivialization of the Holocaust, through
false equivalencies between concentration camps
and vaccine requirements by employers and schools
were. That was listed as one of those things, and
I did see the video. I'm not going to play it, but
you can certainly find it if you are interested.
Liz wrote to me about a weird new Republican
conspiracy. Liz says, Hey David, I've been hearing
an argument being made by some of my right wing
friends that I'm having trouble connecting with
any factual reference point. Shocker. I know,
but I try to understand what frightens the right,
and I can't figure out where this one came from.
They seem convinced lately that the government
is monitoring any transactions over $600 in
our private bank accounts. Where is this
talking point coming from? Is it true?
I have not heard anything about this, so I don't
even know how to remotely deal with this as an
argument against supposed government overreach. So
here is my suspicion about where that comes from.
There was one point at which the false rumor
was being spread that the $600 stimulus from,
I believe, the Trump era, the $600 COVID stimulus
was it 600 that it was going to be taxed as
income. So you get money from the government, then
you pay taxes on it. Now, it wasn't true. If you
got $600 from the government, you were supposed
to report it on your taxes and then in a separate
part, your ass. Did you get COVID stimulus? You
put your ass and you put in the amount and you get
a credit. So it offsets its just reporting, right?
It doesn't change your taxable income, I say.
On the one hand, here's $600 I received. On
the other hand, here's a credit that's $600
is deductible. It zeroes out, OK? I wonder if the
government is monitoring transactions. Over $600
is somehow related to the previous false rumor
that the COVID stimulus money would be taxable.
I don't know, and this is a funny thing. Every
day there's a new one of these, and sometimes
we know where it comes from. Sometimes we
don't. Sometimes hilariously or tragically,
these come from just misunderstanding
some other false conspiracy delusion.
So I don't know. But my suspicion is it has
something to do with the false claim that
the COVID stimulus money was going to be
taxed. Also lastly, today from the mailbag,
Andrew wrote to me about hypocrisy and says.
David, just want to point out the hypocrisy here
for a party so consumed by statistics and how the
one percent that die from COVID isn't a big deal.
Why are they so concerned? About 10000 Haitians
coming to Texas, which is only about three point
five percent of Texas's 29 million well, and not
only that, only a fraction of them would actually
stay in Texas, which is another issue. Yeah.
Listen, Andrew, it's not. None of it's logical.
None of it's logical you can try to present.
You can try to present empirical data to these
folks. It doesn't make a difference if they've
decided it's an invasion of Haitian migrants,
as Trump said, who have AIDS? As other Republicans
have said, who will, you know, suck the country
dry of resources or whatever? If they've convinced
themselves of that, no data that you present is
going to change their minds. That's fundamentally
what it comes down to. And at this point, it
shouldn't come as a big shock. We've got a great
bonus show planned for you today. There's another
show every day we do the one hour broadcast show
podcast. That's this that you're listening to
watching right now. Excuse me. And then we do
an additional bonus show just for our members.
You can sign up at join Packman dot com. Use the
coupon code felony 21. It's such a big discount,
it should be a felony. I think actually Ted Cruz
wants to make it one, but we're pushing against
that big discount felony. 21. Join Pat McCollum.
Unidentified: See you on the bar!